white supremacy it's like one of the
rarest things in this country it's
happened to Alex Jones
Milo innopolis Richard Spencer the list
goes on all of these individuals were
deep platformed or kicked off of
different web services after those
services deemed comments they made
hateful a characterization they all deny
we are experiencing what we see is a
wave of deep platforming right now
oftentimes when we talk about deep
platforming we talk about someone losing
their account on social media but deep
platforming can exist in many different
ways the platforming isn't just limited
to individuals the tactic is also being
used to silence extremist websites
shortly before he allegedly murdered 22
people at a Walmart in El Paso Texas
Patrick rusia shared his manifesto to an
obscure web forum called 8chan website
8chan that's where the suspected gunman
in Saturday's attack posted a four-page
anti-immigrant manifesto this wasn't the
first time that an alleged mass shooter
had posted a manifesto to ei-chan the
individuals who allegedly carried out
the Christ Church mosque shootings and
the Poway synagogue shooting also posted
their manifestos to 8chan but this time
the response to the shooting was
different CloudFlare an Internet
infrastructure company decided to de
platform or stop providing its services
to hñ effectively shutting down the site
at least for now there are about 1
million users of 810 810 is an empty
piece of paper for writing on in
response to the takedown each hands
owner Jim Watkins posted this video to
YouTube it is clearly a political move
to remove hñ from CloudFlare it has
forced a lot of people to find other
places to talk
[Music]
today d platforming is the most popular
tactic to deal with extremist content
online but does it actually work it's
not necessarily going to create a causal
chain where we get rid of hate online
but what it does do is it disrupts this
community of people that have been
building over the last 5 years a culture
of harm and harassment and incitement
according to Professor Donovan D
platforming might slow the growth and
the impact of these websites but it
can't wipe their ideology away entirely
the individuals who carry out such
attacks are not the lone wolves the
media often portray them as donovan says
noting that their manifesto suggests
they are part of a growing in global
white supremacist movement when we say
that their lone wolves what we're
pointing to is that these are
disaffected people who live in isolation
and are coming out of nowhere to conduct
this violence instead the research is
actually pointing to that these people
are never alone that they reach out
online they have a lot of questions
mostly they look into white supremacist
theories of how political parties and
media are colluding to keep white people
down it wasn't that long ago that Scot
earnest believed in that white
nationalist narrative I got involved by
accident it was 2004 and I was just
searching the internet I'm not even sure
what I was doing just surfing and I came
across a blog like many young extremists
earnest was radicalized online
eventually it did become a community
thing you get in there and you meet
these people and I mean even if you if
you don't necessarily like all of them
you know you start feeling connected to
them he eventually became a moderator on
storm front a popular white nationalist
website it's for all white Nationals so
you could be you could be a moderate you
could be extreme you could be KKK you
could be an SM National Socialist he
says he began to distance himself from
the movement as it became more violent
a lot of the movement actually believed
in the mass shootings in an email to the
Wall Street Journal storm from its
founder Don black said we have always
clearly stated that we do not tolerate
any posts even suggesting illegal
violence any such posts are immediately
deleted by moderators and the user
banned the first time I ever questioned
why I was in the movement was when
Anders Breivik shot a bunch of kids in
Norway that caught my eye because at
some point previous to that Anders
Breivik had actually been on my Facebook
run list under the name of Andrew
Berwick Brevik who murdered 77 people in
2011 has since become an icon of sorts
for white nationalists on sites like hn
users have celebrated his kill count for
years and done so legally that's because
vile or not the racist and violent
speech often found on sites like a chant
is protected under the First Amendment
there's much discussion about social
media its implications the harms done
and the question is posed what should
government do about social media civil
libertarians like John samples are
skeptical of any government reforms
arguing that regulation of speech will
backfire and be abused we have very
strong protections and that's going to
mean that there's not much government
can do but that hasn't damped calls for
reform for her part professor Donovan
would like to see legislation regulating
the amplification of hate speech online
[Music]
individuals who own websites are allowed
to decide what stays and what goes
that is non-controversial but when we
run into the problem of scale when that
speech scale so that it is comparable to
broadcast when you have 5060 thousand
people that are looking at particular
posts or videos online that contain
racist speech hate speech harassment
incitement then we have to come up with
a schema related to amplification like
we did with broadcast radio like we've
done with television the
sets a different set of rules for
decades now radio and television
stations have had to follow regulations
meant to ensure they serve the public
interest based in part on the reach
although the internet is different
donovan says it's clear our current laws
have not kept up with our technological
advancements and that perhaps we should
consider a new framework you can say
that any regulation around what someone
says online is protected but I know
that's clearly not right today
the third way forward is already in the
works Zuckerberg announced that Facebook
is creating an independent body that
will review controversial content it's
not clear to me that we want a private
company to be making that kind of a
fundamental decision about you know what
is political speech and how should that
be regulated in a blog post addressing
the El Paso shooters manifesto the chief
executive of the web services company
CloudFlare wrote that a trans
lawlessness had contributed to multiple
horrific tragedies and as a result
CloudFlare would no longer be supporting
the site but cloud flares post also
highlighted how some web service
companies are being thrust reluctantly
into the role of policing speech
CloudFlare wrote we continue to feel
incredibly uncomfortable about playing
the role of content arbiter and we do
not plan to exercise it often